what up space fan golson here from anime
outpour and today i am back to discuss
the latest
craziest developments in the one piece
story if you enjoy these one-piece
reviews and want to keep them coming the
best you can do is show some love for
one piece by smashing that like button
and sharing this video
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell or you will miss future one piece
videos
remember to check out my one piece
playlist in the description below
for hours upon hours of one piece
content including content about the
yonko warlords
supernova and more as always there will
be manga spoilers we are talking about
the latest chapter chapter 982
after all now without further ado let's
jump into it
this chapter is called ruffian meets
ruffian a ruffian is defined as a
violent person especially one involved
in crime
in short it's a troublemaker and we know
practically everyone here could fit that
description
pirates are all technically criminals
after all nonetheless
this title suggests that we will be
getting an important clash between two
troublemakers in this chapter
which is something huge that we can look
forward to we're back at onigashima
remember that last chapter a bunch of
stuff happened chopper was spotted by
big mom and marco the phoenix showed up
at wano and made sure that big mom's
family wouldn't be present for the big
fight by knocking them down the
waterfall just as king did before now we
just need pell the falcon in here the
next time the big mom pirates are making
their way up and we can get a flying
zone hat trick we start out with some
more black maria glory instead of
joining the other flying six members and
searching for kaido's son
black maria stays by kaido's side at
first kaido is upset
telling her she has a job to do but she
tells him to relax since there are
already plenty of people searching for
his son
clearly she isn't one of the flying six
members that are trying to take the
position of an all-star
she tells kaido that she'll stay right
here as she cuddles up against him
clearly being a yonko has its
perks and black maria's huge size
actually makes her a good fit for the
also huge
kaido kaido finally relaxes and agrees
with her saying it's time for
celebration
keep in mind they think that the samurai
threat has been dealt with once and for
all because kundra did not make it to
them yet
orochi is also glowing thinking about
how after 20 years the kozuki ghosts
that he's been fearing are finally gone
you'll never see orochi happier
than he is in this panel and the
contrast is sure to be all the more
satisfying when he finally finds out
that the ghosts he fears are still very
much alive
and ready to carry out their revenge
orochi explains that kundra was supposed
to come with the captains who sunk the
red scabbard ships but as we know
because of complications he was left to
find his
own way without any assistance kaido is
relieved saying he thought he might have
accidentally killed him and when you're
kaido
you probably do accidentally kill a lot
of people kaido also mentions laughtale
the final island with the one piece
that odin visited with goldie roger
kaido is clearly still trying to find it
unlike whitebeard who was not interested
but
apparently odin didn't give his
retainers any clues about it
then the traitor finally makes his way
to the yonko and orochi with his
giant ink brush he causes a ruckus
because he keeps knocking people out
who are probably mistaking him for an
enemy and attacking him clearly kundra
is strong
since he can just beat up beast pirates
while holding momonosuke in his other
hand
although it's lucky that he didn't run
into an all-star or flying six-member
he couldn't reason with because that
would not have been so easy to deal with
orochi is overjoyed to see
kanjuro and kaido tells his man to stop
causing trouble since kanjuro is one of
orochi's men
and we really get a sense of how big
kundro is here he's so tall
that his head pops out of the panel and
momonosuke looks like the size of a
basketball in his hand
he's introduced by his full name
kanjorokurozumi
and his full title shogun orochi's
betrayer i checked and it turns out
kanjiro is 11 feet and 5 inches tall
so it makes sense that he towers over so
many people it's pretty ironic that
someone who stands out so much in height
and appearance
turned out to be the traitor that no one
could pinpoint kundro apologizes for
having to cut down
kaido's comrades who took him for an
enemy again showing that he's pretty
freaking strong
despite the fact that he was often used
for comedic relief and oda himself is a
genius for hiding the traitor with
comedic relief too
orochi is still happy thinking
everything went off without a hitch he
sees momonosuke and is
overjoyed that he has the helpless son
of his rival odin in front of him we get
a moment here that addresses something
that was previously foreshadowed
momonosuke wanted to escape as he said
he would
and we saw him looking at a blade
previously it was suggested that he
would use the blade to free himself
evidently he tried to do just that but
then the despicable giant traitor
punished momonosuke
for the attempt by beating him to a pulp
kundro didn't want to take any chances
so he made sure his prisoner couldn't
move
even if he wanted to in contrast to
orochi kaido doesn't look too happy to
see a beaten up kid
again i think kaido has a certain amount
of honor that is completely absent in
orochi he felt bad for taking advantage
of a distraction to defeat odin
he didn't kill momonosuke when he could
have in the past and he had big mom
untied when he could have just killed
her and now rather than being overjoyed
like orochi
he has a kind of disgusted expression on
his face orochi is so amused to see how
kanjuro can beat up his former master
like it's nothing
kundra was completely emotionless about
it despite all the many many years he
spent with the kozuki's
and kundra being the die hard committed
actor he is
says that now that his role is over
momonosuke is nothing but a brat to him
clearly kundra is mentally disturbed
he's a villain who's easy to hate
but his story and behavior definitely
make him an interesting villain
kaido gets a flashback of when he called
momonosuke's dad an idiot lord he could
have killed momonosuke at this point but
he didn't he said he'd let him perish in
the flames of the burning castle but in
reality it seemed to me
like he couldn't bring himself to kill
such a young child especially after the
way he beat odin we also know that
kaido's hobby
is trying to take his own life so who
knows maybe he secretly hoped momonosuke
would come back
stronger one day to take his revenge
perhaps the reason kaido wants to keep
trying to take his own life
is because he feels guilty about his
dishonorable actions in the past we
can't know for sure yet but i think
kaido is definitely more complex than
most people would give him credit for
kylo then says he's disappointed by the
kid
he looks exactly the same as he did back
when he spared his life
still small young and helpless kundro
then throws momonosuke on the ground
calling him
filthy and saying he's hardly worth his
own name kundro truly is a horrible
person and this will definitely make it
all the more satisfying when he gets his
just desserts black maria takes pity on
momonosuke and like us
she recognizes how sad it is that
someone would actually beat him to a
pulp
kaido keeps drinking as if to help him
forget that he's allied with such scummy
people
he's notably serious and quiet in
contrast to orochi who can't stop
smiling and even wants to drink to
conjure a success
finally then kanjiro comes out with the
truth that his plan failed the samurai
and the others are indeed still coming
then we get another hilarious moment
where kandra says that he never imagined
kinemon to be so
calculating kendra still believes that
kinimon managed to outsmart him
and doesn't realize that kinemon himself
made a mistake i'm telling you guys when
this story is told
centuries from now by the people of wano
kinemon will probably be spoken up as a
cold calculating genius
orochi is no longer smiling the coward
of a shogun
is worried again no matter what he can't
escape the ghosts of his past
i almost feel like his mental fear and
torture that he's been carrying for so
long
is as much of a punishment as when they
finally end up putting him out of his
misery for all that he's done
fukuro kudrow the captain of orochi's
ninja squad shows up he lets them know
that there isn't a single ship
at the port although the three ships
that departed haven't returned
and four pirates have been found at the
party namely our four worst generation
pirates luffy zoro kid and killer who've
been causing a commotion in recent
chapters
well except for killer the poor guys
trying to reason with the rest who
always seem to be running into trouble
we get an image of our four pirates and
the image
makes them look so evil it's great you
also gotta respect zoro's pirate hunter
title and killer's murder machine title
zorro comes off as a dude who's crazy
enough to even hunt yonko which makes
him such a legend in the making
obviously he's not strong enough to take
down a yonko yet but i can already
imagine how subsequent generations will
speak of the legendary pirate hunter
zorro when asked why the info that there
were trespassers wasn't brought up
before
fukurokujo mentions that queen is
handling it and he didn't want to ruin
the party also the samurai haven't been
spotted
plus the full force of orochi and
kaido's crew are pretty much gathered at
onigashima
so it doesn't really make sense for them
to worry about it they should be
completely safe but that should
is the key word since things don't
always go as they should
especially when the unpredictable
supernovas are thrown into the mix
black maria being her fine calm self
tells orochi to relax and drink up but
orochi is freaking out he's a weak man
who's always relied on the strength of
others and he can now relax until he is
sure that the samurai are dead
momonosuke knows that luffy is here and
he remembers that luffy promised to
rescue him but he's worried about
kinemon and the others because there are
no ships in
sight but we know that they pulled a
boss move and destroyed the boats
so they wouldn't be tempted to retreat
then orochi fully illustrates how
pathetic someone run by fear can truly
be
he takes momonosuke and announces that
they will kill him
in front of everyone the last remnant of
the kozuki clan this is a huge
development and it definitely adds a
huge sense of urgency to the battles
that are about to take place
this is going to bring up memories of
what happened to yasu and in a way our
characters are probably going to get a
chance to make up for the fact that they
couldn't save yasu by saving momonosuke
we see
law and those with him in the submarine
communicating with nekomamushi and his
group
they are rushing to get to the rear
entrance and everything looks like it's
going according to plan
even though odin is gone his memory is
still very much alive and these guys are
committed to carrying out his will
kamina was right when he said a true man
never dies even when he's killed and
that's definitely the case for odin we
then jump to nekomamushi's team
he's with his guardians and with our
epic phoenix marco himself
marco thought he was gonna be late and
sent a note but he made it at the same
time as our big feline friend
and so he outdid himself again i also
got a kick out of his letter and how he
just signed it marco i don't know why
but i thought that was pretty cool
someone not shown also lets marco know
he made the right choice
marco liked odin so it makes sense that
he'd want to help those carrying out his
will
but he also mentions that word of wano
never made it to sea
thus we have a possible excuse for some
people not showing up that might have
otherwise shown up
still though if marco could figure out
about it there's a chance that others
could
and i feel like shanks would be in the
same boat as marco
he liked odin too and he definitely want
to help carry out his will
not to mention the fact that his straw
hat successor luffy is present the boy
he sacrificed his arm to save before
come on shanks i need to see you in wano
bro we jump to dengiro
who under the disguise of kyoshiro runs
into sasaki as far as we know one of the
strongest of the flying six
denjiro not only figures out that
they're looking for kaido's son
he also manages to chain up sasaki
rendering him unable to battle
he thus took out a very powerful
opponent with minimum effort
and that in epic fashion shows off his
odin tattoo on his back
danger continues to be an mvp in this
arc
although i feel like if this wasn't
shonan he would have killed sasuke
rather than just
gagging him leaving someone as
troublesome as sasuke alive
seems unlikely when you're in the middle
of such a huge war
that you've been planning for for
decades we're told that the metaphoric
noose tightens around kaido's neck
as the forces surround him from all
directions we get an epic panel of
dangerous face
things look like they're going real well
but we must remember that every noose
that tightened around kaido's neck in
the past
snapped so it definitely won't be easy
for a dude especially now
that they know our samurai and pirates
are coming and that they have arguably
the most important figure of this war
momonosuke as a hostage we jump to big
mom and chopper who made eye contact
last chapter i wasn't sure which way
this would go
would big mom's head damage lead her to
recognize chopper as a friend or with
all her memories back would she
recognize him as an enemy well we got
our answer here chopper and usop got a
direct hit on her but it only irritates
the yonko she recognizes them as straw
hats
and tells them that she wants their
captain's head like the rest of her
family she wants to wipe out luffy and
restore
any injury that he did to her crew's
reputation
although scared of the yonko chopper and
usop succeed in leading her in the
opposite direction
allowing the samurai to carry out their
plans it never fails to impress me how
you can always count on ulstop when the
chips are down no matter how scared he
gets
and that pretty much applies to chopper
as well in the meantime
nami's group runs into prometheus who
recognizes nami as the woman who stole
zeus he's hot and angry while nami staff
with zeus
shakes nami is scared and this could go
either way at this point
will nami lose zeus i hope not or will
she somehow gain prometheus too
who would benefit her greatly with her
climate focused powers
that would make nami quite a force to be
reckoned with especially compared to
where she started from we then get
another cute moment with ulti
and page one ulti is acting like their
boyfriend and girlfriend while page one
just wants to get her off his back
ironically not only does she not leave
him alone she actually jumps on his back
asking for a piggyback ride it's
hilarious how page one falls straight on
his face
and he falls right in front of luffy
ulti and luffy make eye contact and thus
the two ruffians meet ulti with a
serious face
asks luffy what he wants and luffy with
a serious face
responds that he was gonna ask her the
same thing this moment really emphasizes
how similar these two
are both always speak their mind
completely ignoring societal
expectations
and common sense as well finally luffy
has met up with some flying six
opponents
and will hopefully get a real fight in
the next chapter we got the short apu
scuffle
but nothing really prolonged now next
chapter
we may get to see ulti's true powers and
we may get to see luffy really go at it
or at least he may leave them for zorro
or killer
with big mom chasing straw hats marco
and the rest making their way
to their destinations orochi about to
kill momonosuke
and kaido's son about to be found things
are probably going to get
real crazy in the next few chapters and
i can't wait
let me know what you're looking forward
to the most in the next few chapters
if you did enjoy this review and want to
keep them coming the best thing you can
do is show one piece some love by
smashing that like button and sharing
this video let's see if we can get
something epic like 5 000 likes on this
one
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell or you will miss future one piece
videos
yesterday i dropped an all paramecia
fruits in their powers explained video
so you can check that out while you wait
for the next chapter
link in the description i'll also link
my entire one piece playlist below if
you want to see videos about the yonko
warlord supernova and more as always
feel free to leave suggestions for
future one-piece videos
you would like to see in the comments
below lastly the youtube ad rates have
significantly
dropped recently so the help and support
we're getting from our anime opera
patrons is now more important than ever
a very special thank you goes out to our
patrons over on patreon who help us
survive these youtube issues and who
help make videos like this one possible
first and foremost i want to thank the
legend acknowledged by lord tuigo
himself effort a
and the one tier patrons the ones who
stand atop all clans
steven and grata alola and autumn the
world steelers acquire respect but they
have a jonathan king
desi d brandon of isles papa smurf the
school bus
king riser emperor otaku richie martinez
and thomas jones and our pro hero tier
patrons the one and only gilgamesh
nothing but a fan jason wilson kings out
just anatoly kazatsky angel cruz cricket
xp
joel stanton very gucci alicia actor
jessica k lafond kinokami and water
bonnie park zodiar12 rethuan deora
tienhuang
cynical kraken fulgus77 and deadly
saints thank you all so much
if you enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to patreon.com
anime pro and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar
if you do soil gear name featured in
future videos alongside these amazing
people
right here and you'll even get access to
our private patron only discord where we
talk about anime
life and of course dank memes so check
out patreon.com
anime out for a link in the description
if you're interested you can also now
join the youtube channel and support
more content that way if you prefer
whichever way you choose to support us
you can get the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you